can you imagine the Harry Potter
franchise without Ginny Weasley yeah
it's pretty difficult to do but the
actor who played this iconic character
thinks Ginny deserved way more time on
screen Bonnie Wright recently appeared
on Michael rosenbaum's inside of you
podcast where she opened up about the
disappointment she felt as a result of
the material she was given to work with
when it came to Bringing Ginny Weasley
to life it's
[Music]
all just a memory Bonnie Wright wasn't
too pleased with the time on screen and
character development she got as Ginny
Weasley in the Harry Potter franchise
and she hasn't been shy about telling
the world how she feels there were parts
of the character that just didn't get to
come through because there weren't the
scenes to do that she explained maybe my
anxiety was about like oh I'm going to
be seen as like badly portraying this
character rather than later realizing I
wasn't really given the opportunity to
do that so it wasn't really my fault
when Wright was cast as Ginny in the
first film of the franchise Harry Potter
and the Sorcerer's Stone in 2001 she
didn't even have any lines at all but I
didn't have a line in the script to the
point and then Christopher Columbus gave
me a line on the first day so I was very
excited to suddenly be saying good luck
as Harry sort of goes through into the
platform now despite getting a line on
the spot it's clear that Jenny was not
one of those characters who got the most
focus in the film adaptations I think a
lot of the time you know the audience
didn't really ever get to see much of
Ginny and I think here hearing from what
people have said they've always wanted a
bit more of her of course Ginny got more
opportunities to Showcase who she was as
the franchise progressed but Jenny's
character development in the film still
paled in comparison to that of the books
knowing that's ghostly plenty of fans
who'd been familiar with the books were
well aware of this as was right herself
today right is 32 years old and it's
been over a decade since she filmed a
movie as Ginny Weasley for the final
time matcha Harry Potter's cast was very
young when they started filming the
franchise and of course they spent a
huge chunk of their adolescence bringing
these characters to life Bonnie Wright
was only nine years old when she first
stepped into Ginny Weasley's shoes and
by the time she finished she was 19. yes
I was nine and then I went yeah for in
total just two auditions it's clear that
Wright nailed her surprisingly quick
audition process despite the fact that
she didn't imagine that she'd end up
being chosen as Jenny from 9 to 19 years
old as I was in the series like that's a
massive period of your life where like a
lot is going on still Wright was happy
that she was able to live a relatively
normal life during what she refers to as
her awkward teenage years there were
certainly some unique challenges when it
came to starting out so young in such a
massive franchise it's been definitely
jumping into the deep end so it's been a
quick learning process but I think
everyone's who works on these films is
so passionate and Wright is clearly
happy with the surprising experiences
she got from Landing this once in a
lifetime role it's mature dessert quite
quickly and and sort of made us
understand what makes everyone want to
be involved in film Wright is very open
about the discrepancy between what she
expected she would be able to do as
Ginny Weasley and what the script
ultimately involved still even though
Wright thought Ginny needed more screen
time in the films there were some ways
in which she ended up with more to do
than she first thought when Wright first
took on the role of Ginny Weasley all of
the Harry Potter books hadn't come out
yet every time a book came out now you
know I was there at the bookstore the
day it came out like everyone else like
reading it consequently Ginny hadn't yet
been established as Harry Potter's love
interest don't be so mean and it wasn't
something that right saw coming it's
quite weird I think when I finally
realized and I read the book and you saw
where where they went this is the
relationship sure Ginny Weasley may have
unarguably had more scenes to work with
in the book series than she did in the
film franchise but watching Ginny become
the titular Wizard's love interest was
certainly an interesting and unexpected
development it's quite surreal sort of
still really interested in why they were
drawn towards each other Ginny and
Harry's romantic relationship wasn't
immediately easy for Wright to
understand it's just his sense of of no
safeness they both find in one another
eventually though the character's
attraction to each other became clearer
and clearer it's his sense of belonging
it's the only kind of home he has is the
Weasley family and I guess she
represents all of that in just one
figure the actors in the Harry Potter
franchise had their work cut out for
them in a unique way and had one big
challenge that most actors don't they
were embodying characters that lots of
people knew already very very
well this challenge weighed heavily on
right and it made the differences
between Ginny Weasley in the books and
on screen even more obvious you do look
at it with slight trepidation because
you know all these hundreds of millions
of fans are reading the book and they
have their vision of the character fans
preconceived notions of the franchise
based on the books certainly put Jenny's
lack of room to grow in the films under
the spotlight and likely made it more
frustrating for right to work with we
want to sort of do as much Justice to
the character as possible yeah at first
it was very challenging I think the
sixth one especially I think there's
just so many different sort of areas she
finds herself in and emotions that she
has to sort of I have to show still
Wright found a way to bring her own
twist to who Ginny Weasley was and was
able to flesh out the character on
screen I think I just found it I think
the more I got into it the more sort of
involved and excited I got by sort of
complete eating a scene Wright wanted
more of an opportunity to turn Ginny
into the powerful relatable beloved
character that she became in the book
series unfortunately when it came to
adopting such a long detailed and
extremely well-known series into films
it was inevitable that many characters
and details would have to be shaved down
or even cut entirely while plenty of
characters and key moments had time to
shine in the film franchise Ginny didn't
get to become quite the well-developed
character that she was in the books for
fans who experienced both the books and
the movies this was very apparent they
must have been looking for something
according to Wright doing the version of
Ginny Weasley that many of us met on the
page Justice was always hard to do she
explained that many of her character
scenes were chopped down from the book
to the film The adding so you kind of
didn't really have as much to kind of
show in the film it's hard to imagine
how difficult it would be to try to
bring a well-known character to life on
screen as it is but it would be made all
the more challenging if you didn't get
the time and tools to fully flesh the
character out right certainly felt this
pressure I definitely feel there was
anxiety towards sort of Performing and
doing the best thing she recalls
thinking oh gosh will I do justice to
this character that people love still
despite the struggles that Bonnie Wright
felt along her decade-long journey we
can't imagine another Ginny Weasley
might I suggest someone from my own
house and it's clear that a lot of that
is because of how Jenny and Bonnie
Wright really grew up together he's
become you know a very confident sort of
young woman really she's kind of quite
quite clever and fearless about kind of
what other people think she's very
independent and driven and much of what
Ginny became was thanks to Wright's
exploration of the character it made me
sort of really challenge myself and sort
of find new emotions for her to sort of
explore how right Ginny grew up is
clearly inextricably linked I think
everyone knows where they were
personally and where they were in their
character Wright can relate where she
was in her real life as she watches
Ginny Weasley on screen and it's clear
that no one could understand this
character quite the way she does I think
when you read a script you have to find
a character that you really connect with
in order to play it how do you think
book Ginny and film Ginny compared I I
don't know did she deserve more screen
time together we should cast ourselves
into the future
let's discuss in the comments and for
more videos like this one be sure to
like And subscribe to the things
thank you